I'm glowing I might not be Asian glowing
but I'm glowing from the inside out I'm
going from the outside hi my name is
Elton Keung former owner of Oba seven
aspiring owner laboratory and people are
gonna try my alcoholic boba for the
first time today I've always wanted to
try alcoholic boba it sounds delicious I
think it's going to be so great I think
this will be a beautiful union hey first
drink they'll be trying is the green tea
Heineken with honey green tea Heineken
and honey both on the bottom this looks
delectable this is fun already oh my
love so good I love it it just smells
like beer to me I always fall asleep
when I drink so having green tea and
caffeine I feel like is a great idea you
actually don't taste the beer after a
while that's like how tailgating is
always a weird part where you're like
sucking it up in the note second drink
is the taro with Moscow Moscow is a
smoky tequila oh wow oh my god
this innocent-looking lilac I was like
that drinks gonna be a breeze and then I
took that first step and I was like you
know there's like a lot of alcohol in
there this is like an x-rated milkshake
all of a sudden the alcohol just hit me
like oh my god oh happy I get the hot in
here if I had to describe this as a pop
star
it's a Rihanna the boba gasm which is a
white russian with boba oh oh wow
Asian butter beer is the thing I didn't
know was missing from my life
oh so the the boba had alcohol in it
there is a God and she loved us this is
my favorite one it's like the drink that
you want to just curl up on the you know
couch watch TV watch some Netflix
I love how creamy it is I don't think I
can drink regular Bull anymore
that was a spiritual journey that I
won't forget that was amazing that was a
revolution for my mouth thank you guys
for making these drink so much to boba
and alcohol